[Musique]
les trois cadres mis à pied lundi
travaillait au technocentre de
guyancourt
ils sont soupçonnés d'avoir diffusé à
l'extérieur des informations sur les
projets de véhicules électriques un
dossier stratégique est un enjeu énorme
pour renault et son allié japonais
nissan
joint par téléphone ce jeudi après midi
le responsable de la communication au
technocentre confirmait ces éléments en
précisant que la procédure en cours
portaient sur des actes sérieux
en revanche il insistait sur un
traitement de la sphère disproportionnée
selon lui en regrettant notamment que
nos confrères du parisien et publié le
nom et la photo des trois cadres
concernés
on ne peut rien dire en interne car le
droit du travail s'applique l enquête
est en cours
du côté des représentants des salariés
au technocentre denis de dieu de la cfdt
joint par téléphone affirment avoir
découvert la sphère dans la presse comme
tout le monde
ce n'est que ce jeudi matin soit trois
jours après les faits que le numéro deux
du groupe patrick pelata s'est adressé à
l'ensemble des collaborateurs par un
courrier pour mettre un terme aux
rumeurs
ils demandent leur discrétion et leur
réserve sur cette affaire pourquoi ils
ont est onu premiers jours de l'année
un pur pour sanctionner les salariés à
devoir le service sécurité
un débarqué dans le technocentre et puis
ramenée à l'extérieur les jambons un
tout le monde se pose des questions
c'est acquis c'est ici c'est qu'il
prochain quoi on peut se poser aussi
légitimement ce type de problème est
sacré quand même une ambiance type pas
folichonne
les saints la formation elle a eu on
reste c'est à dire ce sont les
informations ont été communiquées par la
presse nous ce que l'on demande
notamment un rouleau c'est de rencontrer
les organisations syndicales projet
beaucoup plus de précision pour
l'instant trois personnes soit mise à
pied conservatoire pour nous ils sont
pressurés présumé pour l'instant
innocents nous parle d'espionnage vous
parle d'un tas de choses et que les
médias comédie avant que les salariés et
les salariés d'autres réformes est ce
nous paraît quand même pas très logique
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs mes chers amis
permettez moi tout d'abord de féliciter
michel et espina pour le renouvellement
de son mandat pour conseil général et
cela pourrait s'appeler la victoire
modeste
guy malandain la jouer sobre dimanche à
trappes pourtant sa victoire a marqué
les esprits
c'est l'une des nombreuses pertes du
parti communiste mais ici tout était
joué au premier tour où il avait devancé
de peu le maire sortant communiste
jacques moncaut les deux listes ayant
fusionné guy malandain l'a emporté
facilement avec 63 points 55% des voix
dimanche face à la candidate de droite
marie noëlle senti qui ne pouvait que
prendre date
lors de la soirée électorale signer
toutes ces idées toutes ces échanges
qu'on pût qu'on pu voir le jour
pendant la campagne électorale j'ai pas
envie de laisser lettre morte
et j'ai vraiment envie de continuer de
fédérer toutes les toutes les idées les
énergies qui ont pu
qui ont pu ce jour le jour pendant
pendant ces quelques semaines
quant à guy malandain s'adresser aux
perdants communiste dimanche soir ce qui
me paraît essentiel pour répondre à
votre question c'est c'est que
l'alternance se soit fait à gauche avec
une gauche rassemblée au deuxième tour
c'est ça qui est fondamental pour le
militant que je suis pour le responsable
politique que je suis comme je le disais
tout à l'heure aux habitants qui
assistaient aux résultats puisque on
voit que dans de nombreuses villes de la
région île de france mais aussi de la
province l'alternance se fait entre la
gauche la droite et que la gauche perd
beaucoup de villes et que le parti
communiste père des villes aussi et donc
je préfère à cause de mon histoire
personnelle à cause de mon engagement la
situation de trappe où il ya alternance
à gauche mais on garde la ville à gauche
[Musique]